for fans of horror movies halloween
isn't just one day in october
it's an axe wielding monster mashing
year-round state of mind
but you don't have to be david s
pumpkins to enjoy the spookier things in
life
how's it hanging all you have to do is
make sure you watch the very best horror
films that movie-making maniacs have to
offer
lucky for you 2018 has already provided
you with plenty of horror movies you
might have already missed
so hollow out that pumpkin and stick it
on your head here are a bunch of horror
movies from 2018 that you haven't seen
but probably should
we have such sites to show you
[Music]
annihilation beautiful awesome
restrained
and challenging annihilation is the best
film of 2018 that
odds are you haven't seen the movie
focuses on the aftermath of a meteor
strike that's given rise to an
inexplicable phenomenon with a wide area
of earth enveloped in an ever-expanding
shimmer
when five investigators enter to figure
out what's going on they find a
disorienting pocket world that's slowly
remixing itself in gorgeous disturbing
dangerous ways
it's a horror premise that creeps up on
you with the implication of the story
being nothing less than the doom of the
world
the second film from ex-machina director
alex garland it's a masterfully creepy
movie that deserves more attention than
it got in theaters
the endless indie filmmakers justin
benson and aaron scott morehead have
spent their careers putting together a
respectable catalog of genre-bending
films and the endless just might be
their best
casting themselves in the lead roles the
writer directors tell a story of two
brothers who flee a suicidal ufo cult
returning in adulthood to re-evaluate
the life they left behind
they discovered that there may indeed be
magic at the heart of the hippie
collective but if it's real
what does the otherworldly force
protecting the group want in return
made for very little money you only
notice the endless is low budget because
you're impressed by what they pull off
with beautiful cinematography and a
gorgeous california location
it's among the prettiest movies on this
list with a sense but not seen horror at
the heart of the story keeping things
tense through the whole run time
it's horror by way of hp lovecraft with
a story that sticks with you
low life it's not often that you get to
call a movie unhinged and really mean it
but lowlife
more than fits the bill a violent genre
bending almost farce that straddles the
border between horror
high comedy and human drama low life is
admirable for being both audaciously
plotted and technically slick
not cool calling me a nazi you don't
know my struggle
set in the scummy underbelly of los
angeles lowlife focuses on a number of
small-time criminals whose stories all
converge around an organ harvesting plot
gone wrong
it's a nightmare inspired by pulp
fiction but unlike most copycats this
one stands on its own
the end result is intense hilarious and
gross
despite feeling like it shouldn't work
at all low life is one of the year's
best and most savage
thrill rides marrowbone a quiet
self-assured mood piece of a horror
movie set in 1969
marrowbone introduces a mother and her
four children in the northeastern united
states
after the mother passes away the
children must maintain the illusion of a
healthy family in order to avoid being
made wards of the state
at the same time there's also a
supernatural threat within the walls
threatening to tear the family apart
from the inside out marrowbone received
middling reviews from critics having
some controversial late-game turns in
its plotting
but the twists in the story are
elegantly laid out even if you don't
like where the plot goes it's still a
well-designed movie accomplishing
everything it sets out to do with
patience and reserve
downrange on a road trip down an
isolated back road on a hot summer day
the tire of an suv explodes
as the young passengers set about making
repairs they're attacked by an unseen
sniper
who picks off a few victims leaving the
rest to huddle behind cover as they try
to figure out how to survive
like all good horror movies it's a
situation you can imagine yourself in
however outlandish it may seem
but downrange is more than just a good
concept it's good filmmaking with
quality gore effects giving every bullet
a real impact
it may devolve into campy territory by
the end but it stays entertaining all
the way through to watch the characters
struggle to puzzle their way out of
danger
if there even is any gonjium haunted
asylum
based on the local folklore surrounding
a real-life creepy location
gonjium haunted asylum is a korean
horror movie that wears its found
footage influences on its sleeve
easily among the scariest movies on the
list the concept of the movie is classic
forget complex mythologies gonjium is
about spending the night in a haunted
house
the movie follows a group of filmmakers
on a live horror webcast
trying to break a viewership record as
they broadcast live from a notorious
hospital
at first the program appears to be an
exercise in fakery
but the signs of a haunting become a lot
more convincing over the course of the
night
few horror movies capture a sense of
paralyzing dread like ganjium does
if you're looking for pure terrifying
white knuckle horror
it doesn't get much better than this
veronica
you should never believe hype that says
a movie is the scariest ever
in veronica's case it's not even the
scariest movie on this list
but this story of a young teen girl's
possession and slow corruption is a
well-crafted descent into madness
anchored by one strong character and her
otherworldly struggle with evil
veronica introduces the title character
as a caretaker for her younger siblings
mature capable and kind you can't help
but sympathize as something sinister
begins to wake up around her
she resists the evil defending her
siblings from harm like a true heroine
which makes the movie's bleak ending
such a gut punch the overblown hype for
veronica naturally led to a bit of
backlash
but take the movie on its own terms and
you'll get a well-done thought-provoking
possession narrative
not that scary but it's good